uh congrats to you uh sway because I
want to say I just saw uh the record
with post sunflower is is it the most
streamed song ever all right I double a
certified yeah the biggest song number
wise for sure that [__] crazy I
appreciate that too man insane that's
nuts like wow who would have thought I'd
be hanging out with an underage child at
a Taylor Swift eating chicken wings at
4am with a bunch of ratchets and then
you would end up having the number one
biggest song ever it was written man
Odyssey It Was Written yo give me the
background on how sunflower came to be
because it it's really like your record
when post has a verse on it you know
what I'm saying like did you submit that
and and post got on it later like what
was that that process like it was
actually
I got you I got you it was actually
crazy man
um like we was just it was a normal day
you know I'm saying cooking up normal
week
we hit each other up we want to link do
some work Vibe just see where it goes
boom so I pulled up on posters at
electric field you know they was vibing
he was lit turned up like always me and
post always see each other and was
always like good energy you know what
I'm saying so we finally got a chance to
get in together and
boom Lewis Bell was there and just his
whole team was there you know so I
pulled up like solo
boom he was drinking Bud Lights like a
whole lot of Bud Lights I'm I'm from the
country too I'm from Mississippi so boom
we drinking Bud Light spoon cooking
busted out Bud Light so busting down Bud
Light stacking them up on the table like
this he was making like a castle like
after we finished them we just stacked
him up like I think we finished like 17
or something by the time we left the
studio session you drank 17 you no I
only drink like three or four like I
don't even know where the other ones
came from like but everybody's just
adding them to the to the castle and
then boom but they played that
particular beat like it was about
turning on you know what I'm saying a
little boop bop boom bap you know what
I'm saying little Vibe so Boom turn it
on right to that song and like
that was like the third fourth song I
did of the night yeah the night we were
just going back to back like boom and
then that was it that was like the third
fourth song and then we did a couple
more after that but a couple weeks later
like
um they played it for the makers of the
movie and they ended up loving that song
and then just post put his part on there
he mastered it movie Spider-Man's like
singing along to it and [__] yeah that I
see that aspect right there like that
Dynamic that's really like I think
that's the best marketing like a song
can get like something like that like
it's automatically being presented to
this the right demographic you know what
I'm saying the kids and they growing up
with the song you know they're the
future of it so they just streaming as
they get older and older I feel like
it's just
it's The Melodies you know what I'm
saying it's The Melodies it feels good
it's a bright song you know what I'm
saying it just you got a proper look
like everything just lined up perfect
with that song you guys kind of had in
my opinion one of the original like OG
like viral moments in this era of music
with the mannequin challenge I don't
think many people are doing many
challenges prior to the mannequin
challenge no nobody would like black
Beatles was like a real [__] moment
like such a great record but like if you
look back to that like give me like the
the origins of how that started because
that was such a [__] crazy I remember
DJing at the club and playing that [__]
everybody in the whole club will stop
it was a time that was a time now I was
just scrolling through Twitter one day
like you know like you said the kids
know they do everything so I seen the
kids doing some little stuff where they
was freezing and I was like yo let's do
this we did it on stage we had this
cameraman shout out to Eric
he recorded it and the funny thing about
it everybody wasn't really still but he
slowed it down to make it look like
everybody was standing still and then it
just it was a crazy video we put it on
the internet went viral I think I don't
know if I was on tour in Germany at the
time yeah I don't know if I'm correct
yeah because we was on tournament tour
in Germany but I think it went viral on
Thanksgiving or something like that
every year when they do the oh my gosh
the mannequin challenge went viral on
this day it'd always be Thanksgiving I
just noticed that this year you know
what I'm saying I mean last year you did
what I'm saying but I feel like uh
you're a hell of a father Jimmy I feel
like every time I see you you have your
kids with you I feel like you're always
pushing a stroller I've been seeing you
at concerts backstage you got a little
one with you how's fatherhood changed
you in terms of just like approaching
the music [__] approaching your career
just the way that I take like the way
that I present myself is different you
know what I'm saying I don't want to be
serious but not that I don't want to be
but I'm not I'm just not going to do
certain things you know what I'm saying
I'm still gonna be turned I'm still
gonna be lit you know what I'm saying I
want to be somebody my kids can can look
up to though you know what I'm saying so
that's how I move
I love it man how much uh production is
Mike what is uh Mike Will holding down
on this island a lot yeah it's a lot of
Mike Will production but we got a lot of
other great positions too got some got
some slaps on there you got a lot we got
like we got some slaps who else
DJ on the beat so it's a banger Sony
digital Sonny digital
um business boy for real for real huh
yeah for Real Jesus
um
is it a Pharrell beat or a Jack soon
speed for real okay he got him and
Michael actually collabed on it yeah so
they came together on that beat yeah
I got a couple of homies one of my
little young homies I found from Texas
his name Jax
Jason yeah DJ DJ shrimp on there yeah DJ
actually made some hard ass beats too so
he on there boom
okay so we know that there might be some
features on the stand record but what
features do we know for sure when this
interview job
next week I can't let you know yet we
get the album bro it's coming out the
week of the hour We're not gonna let the
cat when I tell you we're not gonna let
the cat out of the bed when I tell you
in the track when I tell you it's big
which one it's two it's only two
features on there okay two of the
biggest like and it's not the hype
biggest they actually like hard artists
like the biggest like like and they got
a lot of hype of course like you know
saying they get all it they got all
these flowers
not confirmed but but kind of confirmed
right he's on the album right well April
7 you know they ain't too far away I
feel like but one of them is like for
this time period like what's going on
everything going on it's going really
light the fans gonna appreciate this
like so much like and it's just like
maybe everybody on there
no no yes I feel like it's going to
spoil it a little bit but everybody
that's on there everybody that's on
there oh they've been on all the other
streamlines but the tracklist drop we're
probably gonna drop that [__] like next
week on the floor it's getting it's
crunch time like
[__] damn April 1st no April Fools
it'd be crazy if post Malone was on the
album
maybe Wayne I don't know you might be my
personal play some April Fool uh pranks
on some people you know what I'm saying
just [__] around with everybody real
quick on Twitter how many songs are on
the project 12 12. I like that because I
feel like your guys's first album was
like very like tight easy digestible
yeah for sure like yeah okay putting
this one aside what's the best swim life
it's a one or two It's gotta be one or
two like the first one yeah and then no
type is my favorite record we ever did
person that record really changed
y'all's life yeah for real yeah just the
way we kicked in the door No Flex Zone
was like a Vibe but no no it was that's
the other deal that's still the one you
know what I'm saying
this that guy still hit like a new song
like when you're performing everything